[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حمار وحشي Gravi هو واحد من ثلاثة
أنواع من الحمار الوحشي الموجودة في
إفريقيا ، وهو الأكبر من بين ثلاثة أنواع من الحمار الوحشي ،
كما أنه أكثر أنواع الحمار الوحشي المهددة بالانقراض
، وهو موجود فقط هنا في كينيا في
شمال كينيا
وإثيوبيا
[موسيقى]
grevi  الحمار الوحشي أكبر بكثير من
أبناء عمومتهم من الحمار الوحشي العادي ، ولديهم
خطوط معقدة أرق بكثير
تغطي أجسادهم ولكن ستلاحظ أن
بطنهم هو هذا
الأبيض المذهل ولديهم هذه
الأذنين
المستديرة الكبيرة ولديهم أيضًا خطم أنيق
مع كمامة بنية
لذا فإن حمار وحشي المرق يحتل هذه
المناظر الطبيعية القاحلة الأكثر جفافاً
، ويمكنه البقاء بدون ماء لمدة تصل إلى أربعة
أو خمسة أيام
بقدر ما أتذكر أنني كنت
أرغب في العمل في مجال الحفظ وهو
ما دفعني للوصول إلى ما
أنا عليه الآن
[موسيقى]
مهمة مؤسسة Gravies من أي وقت مضى هي
الحفاظ
على أعداد حمار وحشي الجرافي وتنميتها في المرق
بشمال كينيا ،
وهي مهمة لأن الحمار الوحشي
يلعب دورًا رئيسيًا في النظام
البيئي وله قيمة بيئية ضخمة
من حيث ديناميكيات السلسلة الغذائية
، كما أنهم يلعبون دورًا مهمًا للغاية
في ثقافات وتقاليد
الناس
هنا
[الموسيقى] ،
لذلك في السبعينيات انخفض تعداد حمار وحشي المرق
من حوالي خمسة عشر
ألف فرد إلى
ما يقل قليلاً عن ألفي شخص ، وكان ذلك في
الأساس  بسبب البحث عن
جلودهم من أجل صناعة الأزياء ،
لكن منذ ذلك الحين شهدنا
انخفاضًا كبيرًا في
جودة الأرض ، لذا فقد تسبب تدهور المراعي
في خسائر فادحة في أعداد حمار وحشي grebby
[موسيقى
] أحب العمل مع المرق حمار وحشي فهي
واحدة  من
أجمل الحيوانات التي يجب أن تنظر إليها
وهي تعيش في واحدة من أكثر
المناظر
الطبيعية الخلابة في كينيا ، الإرث الذي
أود تركه
هو إظهار أن الحياة البرية والناس يمكن أن
يتعايشوا وأعتقد
أه الفرصة لذلك  لدينا مع
حمار وحشي جريفي
يقدم فرصة مثالية لإظهار
كيف يمكن أن يحدث ذلك ويمكن أن يكون
نموذجًا للحفظ
على نطاق أوسع بكثير